okay we have a very interesting video
from former federal prosecutor a Chuck
Rosenberg he went on MSNBC and he was
talking about the molar report which we
now know to be a 400-page report roughly
which Attorney General William Barr
summarized to four pages and he made a
sort of obvious but still clever remark
which is as a prosecutor it never took
him four hundred pages to say that
nothing happened and that no wrongdoing
took place Chuck Rosenberg says the most
likely scenario according to him is that
there were crimes and wrongdoing but
Robert Muller would explain in his
report that he didn't believe it rose to
the level of being able to fire charge
of file charges either because there was
missing evidence or because of the
political implications of filing or
recommending charges against the sitting
president so we're going to dig into
that in a second here because remember
Robert Moeller
I'm guessing knew that Donald Trump's
attorney general had publicly taken the
position a year ago or longer at this
point that a sitting president cannot be
indicted for obstruction so if you're
Robert Muller and you're making a
political calculation you might say
listen I've got 85% of what I believe
would be necessary for an indictment on
obstruction of justice but the guy who
is going to ultimately have to decide
about this the Donald Trump's Attorney
General William bar doesn't even believe
at a sort of overarching level that the
president can be indicted for
obstruction of justice I'm just not
going to go there and that would
actually be extraordinarily problematic
because that is exactly the point of
appointing someone like William bar to
be your Attorney General so let's get to
a little bit of this interview with
former prosecutor Chuck Rosenberg who
you'll notice is very calm and clear in
his demeanor he states when he's
speculating but he defends the
speculation we'd be much better off if
we had more analysts who were like Chuck
Rosenberg he probably flew over the main
justice but putting mode of
transportation aside
no it's never taken me 400 pages to say
nothing happened and so I imagine
something happened and that's something
particularly with respect to obstruction
was quite serious but I have a theory I
think it's plausible as to why mauler
didn't recommend prosecution or
declination on the obstruction it goes
as follows the Department of Justice has
in place policies one dates to the
seventies one to two thousand that say
to charge a sitting president would be
overly burdensome would stigmatize the
presidency and so we just don't charge
sitting presidents with that in mind
even if the obstruction constituted a
crime and it may well have we don't know
that yet I could imagine Muller not
making a recommendation because of
recommendation to prosecute someone you
can't prosecute is equally burdensome in
equally stigmatizing this is just the
most likely and obvious scenario nothing
chuck rosenberg is saying here is
controversial now the one thing i
disagree with is his use of the word
policy for the justice department not
charging presidents it's more of a
tradition which has not been tested in
terms of whether it would actually stand
up to the law i think there is no
question that the founding fathers did
not establish a framework for this
country that gave the president this
type of immunity from and by the justice
department otherwise what chuck
rosenberg is saying is basically it it's
common sense go back to brett
Cavanaugh's confirmation hearings and
the investigation surrounding that
republicans were able to come up with a
report that couldn't definitively pin
sexual assault on Brett Kavanaugh which
of course we knew would be difficult to
definitively pin on him in such a an
investigation that is taking place
decades after it allegedly happened
Republicans took that report which said
we can't definitively say he sexually
assaulted someone and they turned it
into they transformed it like putty in
their hands into the report totally
clears Brett Kavanaugh they hid the
report itself and then it became very
difficult to argue against confirming
him because you had the absence of a
totally unrealistic burden
of proof beyond reasonable doubt against
Brett Kavanaugh you had the report
itself hidden and you had Republicans
saying he's been cleared that's very
similar to what's happening here with
Donald Trump in both cases you have a
report that supposedly clears Cavanaugh
and Donald Trump the report is
summarized by partisan actors hidden at
least so far the Moller report has been
from public view and then the
Republicans use these hidden reports and
political summaries to claim that
there's been an exoneration used in
Cavanaugh's case to justify confirmation
to the Supreme Court in Trump's case to
justify this media tour claiming that he
has been completely cleared of all
wrongdoing and fully exonerated even
though we've not actually seen any
evidence to suggest that that's the case
III know that when I say this people get
mad they've played it really well and
when I say that people say David it's
not that they've played it well it's
that their base is so stupid and
ignorant that they're falling for it
well they've played it as well as they
needed to for the base that they have so
in that sense they have played it well
my question to you today which we also
asked about on our YouTube community
poll do you think we will ever see the
full molar report let me know I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
a quick break we'll be right back one of
today's sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to
you more than you actually want them to
and it protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets five dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below